ja ich freue mich schon mega auf das
heutige video denn meine damen und
herren wir spielen heute
fahrdienstleiter 2017 für 2009/10 hat
das geld nicht so ganz gereicht
von daher herzlich willkommen hier auf
meiner farm meine lieben freunde das
hier ist meine villa in der wohlig ich
habe mich hier mit meiner frau ute so
mega schöne objekt zu schwer dicker
meister nicht was nicht für muskeln habe
das ist auf jeden fall unser kleiner
vorgarten hier
wir bauen hier auch marihuana an und das
hier ist der eingang zu unserer bruder
da können wir nämlich ein
ja das ist blöd weil ich habe den
schlüssel vergessen aber als nicht so
schlimm
wir können doch einfach hier links
langlaufen und dann kommen wir einfach
mal hier lang und wie
[Applaus]
ich steh auf meiner marihuanapflanzen
hier vorne haben wir noch einen zweiten
eingang dackel mit ansprung vielleicht
ja da habe ich auch kein schlüssel für
allerdings haben wir den gartenschlauch
und den können wir wegschmeißen
ich kann ihn auch mitnehmen genau das
wollte ich nämlich tun und zwar wollte
ich mit dem gartenschlauch komm mit ich
wollte alter kann ich denn doch nicht
mitnehmen mit dem gartenschlauch wollte
ich euch nicht weil meine hühner hier
zeigen
das ist die sigrid das ist der 1 das ist
der peter 95 na ja das ist meine hühner
fahren meine lieben freunde
das hier ist unser gästezimmer ab da
schlafen die gäste könnt ihr alle eure
fresse halten bitte vor allem duo peter
allerdings würde ich sagen wir verlassen
weil die hühner jumpen da kommt rüber
und schauen uns das hier an stroh und
heu wenn du für stroh oder heu zahlen
keine sprachen lernen also das ist auf
jeden fall mein ganzes strom ein ganzes
voll mein ganzes gras und hier vorne
haben wir mein silo weil wenn ich
scheiße dann kommt direkt da in den turm
rein ich nenne das bauwerk auch gern
mein nasa sturm weil es sieht aus wie so
eine rakete besteht allerdings aus
meiner scheiße da können wir auch ganz
entspannt weil hier durch das
fragezeichen laufen wenn man sich schon
silos und diese - kannst du darüber ja
das liegt aber kein schwein meine lieben
freunde kann ich jetzt zwischen rhein
fallen
nee das geht nicht weil ich eigentlich
im körper nein
wie sehe ich eigentlich aus das ist auf
jeden fall mein raketen scheiße silo
hier vorne können wir auch mal ich habe
keine schlüssel
falls jemand einbrechen willkommen da
oben dann meine scheiße rauskommen also
das ist auf jeden fall mein raketen
scheiße silo hier vornehmlich von abt
dach gebaut
das sollten eigentlich eine sportwagen
hin aber ich habe kein geld wenn wir uns
da mal so ein bisschen umdrehen sehen
wir hier wo ich mein ganzes glasanbau
davon dass wieder meine villa hatten das
hier ist mein gras gelagert wenn strom
hall genau das hier ist auf jeden fall
da die die farben die ich habe dass sie
vorne ist meine villa hier ist auch das
gewächshaus
das hier ist allerdings eine meiner
maschine
da kann ich mir einfach mal einsteigen
und ihr seht schon ich kann den
auffahren dass das war dass damit das
war voll geplant weil man muss ja auch
die resistenz von diesen dingen testen
mit oka nicht das rohr aus fahne who
also ich ja muss der sibylle recht dem
ich hab schon das längste rohr von allen
bauern im kreis auf jeden fall habe ich
jetzt das ohr ausgefahren das heißt ich
habe mal ist rücklage aha das ist hier
die lupe weil mein gehirn arbeitet immer
so krass und dann darf das manchmal und
dann muss ich kann auch wieder extrem
der partie zu ich kann wieder ex druck
und dann party hatte kann ja noch zu
drücken
herzlich willkommen bei farbigen
simulator mit lukas finde ich weiß
allerdings jetzt nicht ganz genau was
ich machen soll was ich kann auch ist ja
der wahnsinn durch durch dich durch die
techniker der mitmenschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßen ich würde sagen wir
fahren allerdings jetzt erst mal zurück
lassen das ding da liegen und fahren
hier ein wenig zur seite
ich schaue mir noch mal mit in die
steuerung an da ist gerade die facetime
vor für euch im video
ich habe hier noch
ich kannte mal das ist jetzt der
kombination ihr ich muss ich kann nichts
abladen weil ich noch nichts geladen
habe das heißt meine lieben freunde ich
drehe hier jetzt einfach mal und wir
fahren nun auf dieses feld zu
wir müssen allerdings dieses ding da
vorne erst mal daran platzieren ich
parke jetzt erstmal mit meinem komischen
wie heißt das ding
ich steige auf jeden fall mal aus und
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt das ding
irgendwie da genau jetzt will sich
wieder treffen wie kann ich da dieses
blöde ding da anlagen gleich von der
anderen seite wenn ich dagegen fahren da
falle ich auch nur dagegen
aber gut einer lieben freundin zeige ich
euch halt weiter mein bauernhof dass wir
vorne ist meine bank
das ist ein traktor lokale traktor ist
ein mega cool da kann ich auch einfach
erdrückend und kann damit losfahren
er wird schon die beschleunigung ist
wahnsinn das ding kann übrigens auch
puppen war das mein gott wir haben
unfall gebaut tool ist allerdings ich
habe hier vorne auch noch einen will
traktoren können einfach mal genau
dagegen fahren
ich stecke jetzt mal in den anderen ein
weil das coole bei dem anderen traktor
ist dass der blaue ist so wie ich vor
zwei tagen im club der also das hier ist
auf jeden fall der andere trecker den
wir haben nach vorne habe ich noch einen
dritten treffer mehr treffer als
gehirnzellen wir steigen jetzt hier
einfach mal aus er bleibt stehen
ok ich denke man den ja ein dass an dem
hier ist das dass sie hinten nicht
festgemacht ist wie mache ich das denn
fest muss irgendwas drücken
ich musste kohl drücken wels ecken
slater ich habe gerade helfer
eingestellt
wer das für mich macht gut macht er das
auch mit der mit der kurve da jetzt
dreht er jetzt nicht erfährt jetzt genau
gerade da vida und jetzt denken senkte
das auch wieder ab ich bin halt so reich
dass ich mir so gesagt leute einstellen
kann ich würde allerdings sagen ich
parke den trecker jetzt erstmal hier
neben meinem blick aber genauso und
steige aus kann ich in meinen pickup
einsteigen ich kann meinen ich kann in
meinem pickup einsteigen oh der ist ja
sogar ziemlich stellen mein gott und
jetzt kann ich nicht dass ein open world
spielen kann ich jetzt mit dem pickup
irgendwohin fahren in die stadt oder ob
ihr seht sogar andere fahrzeuge das ist
ja wahnsinn kann ich den ram ja das
schadensmodell ist nicht so ganz
vorhanden
[Musik]
kannst du dich bitte verpissen wenn wir
auf die neuen drücken sehen wir schon
unsere karte das heißt ich würde das
auch mein gott wir haben eine richtige
stadt das heißt freunde ich würde sagen
wir fahren jetzt einfach mal zu dieser
stadt hinten rechts ich fahre 122 m
innerorts wohlgemerkt also ich bin ein
richtiger rowdy ein wunder warum den
ganzen bauern weiber auf mich stehen
hier sind wir jetzt heute allerdings auf
jeden fall in der stadt angekommen das
ist auf jeden fall in amerika hat sonst
wären ja nicht über mein gott hallo ich
bin darf meine lieben freunde die
parkbank nett dass das aufatmen das war
ich nicht
es spielt auf jeden fall in amerika
sonst wäre ich nicht weil diese amerika
flaggen
hier ist der laden der heißt hyper cube
hits oh mein gott da gibt es menschen
kann ich die umfang ja lauf einfach
durch meinen pick up durch apropos pizza
meine lieben freunde di luca pizza 3
wahnsinn was den übergang di luca pizza
3 kommt ab dem ersten zwölf den in alle
möglichen revis egk es in deutschland
also seid bereit spitzt die lauscher die
augen und die ohren
die lauscher sind die orden luca ich
würde mich auf jeden fall freuen wir di
luca fischer drei mal probieren würde
das ist er läuft schon wieder durch mein
auto durch es ist die tiefkühlpizza mit
den meisten verschiedenen käsesorten
wir haben sieben verschiedene käsesorten
und noch lauchzwiebeln und obwohl ich
bin halt ein lauf und apropos ich bin
ein lauf meiner lieben freunde ich habe
gerade einen neuen roman der am 11 12
ebenfalls lounge wird allerdings nicht
im supermarkt sondern kabine stoffe.de
bei den rudi haben uns ein bisschen
reifen auch renault orientiert wir haben
allerdings hier keinen polo reiter drauf
sondern wir haben ein alpaka drauf
gemacht und wenn man die kapuze auf hat
steht der lupo eingestickt ja jetzt mit
kassler
allerdings würde ich sagen schauen uns
jetzt nochmal ein bisschen die stadt an
hier ist ein waffenladen da ist ein
handwerks laden da ist ein kuchen laden
hier vorne stehen
kann ich nicht über den hydranten
drüberfahren wie bei gta dass man
plötzlich keine bäume umfallen kann hier
vorne sind auf jeden fall ein paar
wohnhäuser genau jetzt der michi zudem
sei jetzt mal hallo was geht bruder
alles klar bei dir ja ich war halt auf
dem bau ich habe halt bis
für mich ist einfach an mir
vorbeigelaufen aber gut vielleicht
erkennt nämlich einfach nicht wieder
hiervon ist der mani matter gutermann
der arbeit in der bank deswegen hat er
auch nicht mehr holz verbleiben dann wie
ich manni alles bestens bei dir
[Musik]
manni
aber egal da komme der peter peters das
ist das geht bei die arbeiten ich habe
meinen hut nämlich nachdem peter
genommen weil der peter der sieht aus
wie ein huhn rp dabei
schonach die simone weil der alte ex
freund wird er wie sind seine kinder 13
davon leben in afrika die anderen vier
leben bei mir im gewächshaus aber sie
mode ist in alle zukunft welche ich weiß
nicht wie gut auf mich zu springen kommt
da noch unbekannt glauben die ecke bei
gott das ist meine steuer prüferin da
muss ich ganz schnell los aber stecke
ich mich lieber mal hier hinter dem auto
ich hoffe die sieht mich nicht das ist
die ingrid von ingrid dies steuer
prüferin sie schon hier warte ich fahre
hier oben irgendwo eine flunder dort
mein ganzes unternehmer sondern der
inhalt egal aber gut meine lieben
freunde ich fahre jetzt hier mal wieder
durch meinen kleinen zuvor gemacht den
fluchtweg zurück zu meiner scheune da
seht ihr schon dass einer meiner 40
tracks wie hier vorne ist auch bei den
mädels aber volle kanne gegen das ist
doch ein schönes abschlussfoto hier
meine lieben freunde wenn euch diese
folge farming sie mir later 2017 mit
luca gefallen hat ich weiß es gibt schon
farming simulierter 19
ich hatte nicht so viel geld auf meinem
steam-account deswegen konnte ich mir
nur dass sie für 15 euro leisten bei
durch das video dennoch gefallen dann
würde ich mich sehr darüber einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freund schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare was haft hammer bei 6.000 in
der nächsten folge machen soll
vielleicht aber irgendwas mit farming zu
tun hat wenn ihr diesen eventuell
zweiten teil von farmingdale etwa 2017
mit pfizer pharma bis 6000 nicht
verpassen wollt dann abonniert auf jeden
fall gerne einen kanal in dem video ist
es kostenlos ist keine videos mehr und
wenn ihr schon aber deine zeit denn auch
die glocke der damit kommt eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich ein neues
video hochladen
wie bereits gesagt der rudi hier mega
gemütlich mega flauschig kommen am
ersten zwölfter den shop und am ersten
1200 auch die pizza raus und ich
denn dumm
[Musik]